shining a light on the way money moves
through the political system a new tool
from Sky News and partners tortoise
media for everyone to track their MP and
the donations they get for two days
we've been combing through the data top
earners top donors now welcomed by the
Prime Minister I think transparency is
really important and that's why we have
a set of rules and regulations in place
to provide that transparency for people
and it's important that those rules are
adhered to
the current system allows businesses as
well as individuals to give their money
to MPS but it's not always easy to work
out who's behind them the third biggest
donor to MPS in this Parliament is a
little-known firm called npm connect for
weeks we tried to establish who was
behind that money
so we travel to Hertfordshire to the
company's registered address
hello there I'm from Sky News um we're
trying to get in touch with people from
npm connect this is the address for npm
connect Peter Hearn or Simon Murphy did
you know whether I can speak to them or
how I can contact them
do you recognize the names I'm talking
about
you look confused
have you heard of mpm connect accountant
foreign yes have you heard of npm
connect
no luck and our questions to the MPS
unanswered but today a sign that it
doesn't have to be like this weeks ago
we asked Shadow Home Secretary Yvette
Cooper shed a health secretary Wes
treating and Dan Jarvis basic questions
about the firm that had donated Deb
hundreds of thousands of pounds only
today after the Westminster accounts
aired and we had raised those questions
in public did we get a response pretty
straightforward answers The Man Behind
mpm connect is labor supporting
businessman Peter Hearn with basic
information not available to the public
there are those in Parliament trying to
improve the system do you think that it
is helpful to pull all this stuff
together yes in one database yes uh to
make it much more easy for the voters to
understand yes
and why then well done I mean well no so
my question then is if you think it's
such a good idea why haven't you because
or your committee or other MPS done it
before this we've been trying to do this
for the last two years apologies that
we've been slow we've been trying to get
the house to make it its number one
priority and it is now and it was when
we had our meeting in November and I
hope that by the summer we will have a
fully all singing all dancing
um system but I want it to include the
ministerial stuff as well there's a
mixed response from other MPS you're one
of the few that have been willing to
come on to talk to us about their
figures and these are yours from 2019.
it could be construed
um particularly if perhaps you're the
opposition you know down in Bournemouth
to say I've received 43 000 in gifts
that somehow I'm benefittary of that
amount of money and that's I think it
would be I hope you'd agree it would be
misleading so I think it would be
helpful to make sure that that isn't
lost in what you're trying to do which
is ensure that there's transparency here
I've not benefited from 43 000 pounds in
there the response has not been
universally welcoming to the Westminster
accounts a project that makes how many
moves through our political system
visible to the public
some answers today but more questions
Tomorrow Sam coat Sky News